welcome to simply learn as WWLP learn
comm get certified get ahead let's go
ahead and take a look at the Jupiter
notebook for doing your Python
programming in so we're gonna cover the
basics of the jupiter notebook i'm
showing you how it works and what it
looks like let's go ahead and start with
the install if you go to Jupiter or goes
jup
y te r dot o-r-g and click on the
install button and then you can run the
prerequisites Python and downloads here
and you can see the setup on this and
you'll see the very first thing they
suggest is that you install Jupiter
using the anaconda so we have Jupiter
notebook and then we have the anaconda
set up and that's WWE anaconda comm you
just go up to the downloads once you're
under the downloads you'll see in the
anaconda that they have it set for
Version three point seven or two point
seven I generally work in the newer
version although I did had to reset my
anaconda to three point six for working
with Google's tensorflow which you can
do very easily in anaconda this way so I
remember the first time someone showed
me
Jupiter notebook and anaconda I was so
excited because of all the cool things
you could do with it so this is your
install here you can download it open
and run that I happen to be under the
Windows setup it works on Apple works on
Linux well it's nice about anaconda with
just the cool things you can do the
first one was Jupiter notebook so I'm
going to show me Jupiter notebook and
you'll see this you just flip back on
over here for the Jupiter symbol and
then anaconda creates environments so it
makes it very easy to create a Python
3:7 environment with the different
modules installed so if you're working
with a referenced Google tensorflow a
little troubles with that and to go to
Python 3 6 you can easily do that you
can create an environment for Python 3 6
and that's all through the Anaconda
so once you've installed this there's a
couple ways to get to your Jupiter
notebook so you'll go ahead and just
download and run the anaconda install
and then in this case I go into my
windows and I actually have anaconda
64-bit and we can go to and a Conda OOP
there's true paterno book you can
directly access it that way you
do the Anaconda prompt I can do Jupiter
notebook well actually I'm gonna go back
and do this the way I like to do it well
let me just show you what this looks
like when I hit enter on here it opens
up a browser window and I now am in
Jupiter notebook where I can create new
projects and go in here and create a new
file running and we'll look at that in
just a minute
what that means but let's go back a step
I'm gonna go ahead and close out of this
and we'll open up my anaconda and when I
run my anaconda
you'll start up here in just a second
this is the same by the way they have a
shortcut icon it's the same thing as
going down here to see where we anaconda
navigator so I'm running out of the
Anaconda navigator which I just love I
just adore the Anaconda navigator and
the Anaconda navigator comes up with all
kinds of cool tools you'll see over here
I have applications on and it says base
root what you find out is if you click
on environments on the left hand side
base root is the one that that's
defaults to but I also have my data
science I have my stock pole I have
another one it's called no GPU because I
was working with some GPU setup you can
create as many environments as you want
and go down here and create a new
environment I can tell it what I want in
that environment which version of Python
you can click on one of the environments
and clone it at the very end of
environment this little triangle if you
click on there you can open a terminal
window you can open it in different ways
the terminal window then allows you to
use usually like if you're used to
Python use pip install you can use pip
or Conda install Conda does the same
thing as the pip except it looks for all
the dependencies so if I'm in a rush I
use Conda if I am working in this and I
need to be tracking exactly what I
install on here then I use the pip when
you're in an environment don't mix and
match the to stick with Conda or stick
with pip because you can run into
problems with imports and reliance and
stuff like that so we'll go ahead and go
under data science cuz that's what I
enjoy doing data science
so when I go back to my home menu you'll
see my data science opens up and I have
my Jupiter notebook first thing and
there's a lot of tools you can open up
our studio from in here I've never
really used spider that much but spider
is another Python editor
there's a Jupiter lab vs coating so
there's a lot of steps in here there's
even stuff you can add in mostly I use
Jupiter notebook and then occasionally
use our studio so I try to wrap
everything in here the first time you
open Jupiter notebook you'll have this
little install so it doesn't
automatically install the Jupiter
notebook underneath this environment
until you're ready for it and then we go
ahead and just launch it and it's gonna
open it up in whatever my default
browser is it's just gonna go underneath
my Chrome browser and open that and once
it's in the browser I'm now in Jupiter
notebook just like we did the other way
so we did two different ways to get in
here this is I've set this to my data
science setup you'll see down here I
have folders it's actually on my D Drive
I pointed this to my D drives because
where I keep everything and I can go
under simply learn and you can see we
have different tutorials and different
things we've done in here over the years
actually over the last year since this
is a fairly new computer this is over
the last couple months I think well this
one here yet why do we have something
from five months ago but that was
brought up brought it in from earlier so
it's about two months old my computer
and I want you to notice that the
extension on these is I py in B and this
is important because when you create new
Python file to run in here it's gonna
create what they call an ironpython file
so in here you'll see i py in b i'll
just go ahead and zoom in so you can see
that a little better there's our i py
and b and we'll go up here to the upper
right and you can upload data and all
kinds of things in here but we're gonna
start with just creating a new notebook
so I'm gonna click on here and I'm gonna
click this one we're gonna work in
Python 3 so I want to click on Python 3
and by default if you installed 3/7 it's
gonna be running 3 7 I have to actually
set this to 3 6 i went back and change
the environment to make sure it's
running 3 6 in here and we're now
actually running python script so we can
just go right in here and type in print
and everybody does this the hello world
and then i can go up here and click on
the big run button and it's gonna run it
and it's gonna print hello world just
like any notebook i can go up here to
view a toggle header so now my header is
on this is untitled at number 4 we can
click on here and change this
you call this Jupiter notebook basics
and then I'll hit rename and so now you
can see Jupiter notebook basics and if I
hit the little save discs it's now saved
my hard drive so I can go back and open
this up at any time if we go back to
this window
Jupiter notebooks basics right there it
is so and it's running so these are the
files I got up and going and it's got an
open colonel now colonel it opens up a
colonel to execute the program in and
when we're looking at this it's
important to know that it's only setting
up one colonel so everything and your
Jupiter notebook is gonna work great
except for multi processing even
multi-threading works fine and Jupiter
notebook but if you get into both AI
processing you'll start seeing some
problems because it's only opening up
one kernel to run it in here and if we
go under colonel you can see how we can
restart it sure you want to restart it
so any variables that were saved let's
do this B or let's just call hello hello
equals hello simply learn hello simply
learn we'll just print B over here or
hello so if I run this hello is now
stored but if I go up to kernel and I
interrupt if I restart the kernel hello
is no longer stored so if I print hello
I rent it down here it's gonna give me
an error because it's not stored well if
I come up here and I hit run it's now
stored on here and I hit run on this
cell it's also it still continues in
memory so it continues down there as
long as it's not interrupted and this
brings up another interesting point is
we run each cell one at a time so when I
hit the Run button it doesn't go through
all the cell's unless I want it to and
it's so easy to click on the Run button
when you're doing a lot of editing but
there is shortcuts to that I can also do
shift enter and that's the same as
hitting the Run button so it's running
this first cell which is labeled number
four we have our output from that cell
and then we can go down here and run the
second cell there's our output from that
cell so it's literally running one
section at a time and when we go up to
kernel we can interrupt the kernel if
you have a long run you can just stop it
which terminates the program completely
we did the restart which resets the
kernel I always use restart and clear
output which then clears all your
outputs on here so you know that those
aren't saved anymore you can go to our
East
and run all so restart and run all will
start from the top cell they'll run it
and he'll go to the next cell and run it
and it goes all the way down you can
also do the same thing under cell you
can do run cells so it's gonna run the
top cell and go down run cells and
select below you can see how that just
runs the first cell and then moves down
to the next cell then you can do run
cells and insert below run all run all
above run all below pretty self
descriptive so you have a lot of choices
to run the most common is either to
click on the Run arrow or hit the shift
enter to run your code and one of the
really great things about this is and
once you start playing with it it's so
visual I click on the cell and I'm
editing that cell I come down here and
click on the next cell I'm editing that
cell I'm deleting it or whatever I'm
doing on here so you can see it's pretty
straightforward as far as the setup and
these are the most basic editing's you
can do of course is just to put your
code in and because it's such an easy
input it's so easy just to keep
scrolling down and adding new cells in
so that you can go back up and execute
different portions of your program let's
go ahead and do an input we'll set up
there we go let's have a space on there
just so it looks nice
and then it'll put print and let's go
ahead and run this and a couple of
things to know is there's an asterisk
appears here on the left so this piece
of code is running right now and the
inter comes in in line and so I can go
ahead and type in my name Richard hit
Enter it says hi Richard it's our real
quick short program on there this inline
editing an output makes is great for
doing presentations the first time I did
this we were doing a data science
when the huge blowers on the sewage
plant go out these huge aerators and
when they go out they cost a lot of
money to replace and so we're trying to
come up with the code that would look at
the different wobbling so they could
replace the pieces instead of having to
replace a whole aerator so they could
replace the bushing instead of having to
go in there and replace the whole fan
unit the fan unit runs about five to ten
thousand dollars the bushing is an hour
worth of labor
about $10 you know she was doing five
and ten thousand dollars versus ten
dollars is huge so if you could predict
when it starts to wobble too much and
something's going wrong but we did it
eventually so we could actually see the
plots on here and stuff like that and
the output so we'll show that in just a
minute what it looks like to put a plot
on here but just for a quick rehash and
print let's see hope you see you in
class soon
when you run the cells they run top to
bottom and it only runs one cell at a
time so whatever cell like click on
that's the cell that's running and you
can see the asterisk appears it shows
I'm running and once we type in our name
it actually prints whatever the output
is down below in this case enter your
name Richard enter and it won't print
hope to see you in class soon until they
click on this cell and run it and then
you'll see hope to see you in class soon
so you have a lot of control you can
work on one piece of code maybe you're
loading your variables up and then you
can start executing the code based on
those variables but you do have to
remember if the problem is in the cell
above you got to fix that you can't just
keep working on the cell below and
expect it not to change the answer
another important thing to notice this
is a title you know user comments to
comment something else but in Jupiter
notebook I can come in here to the cell
and I can change the cell type to
markdown and you can see and marked out
it changes the colors and everything and
when I run it you know I end up with
this is a title this is a bigger title
so I can create nice titles in here if
I'm working with a project and I'm
actually doing a demo I'm actually doing
some kind of production I'm showing the
graphs and I've generated the graphs
already in my jupiter notebook instead
of going back out putting that into a
presentation I can just open up the
notebook scroll down add my titles in
and I'm ready to go so you can see right
here it's very useful to be able to put
to tag a box as in this case markdown
for our cell and then I mentioned to you
that we can also do our plots in here so
let's go ahead and plot import mat plot
library as PLT very commonly used that
way I'll do a plot let's just keep it
simple
1 2 3 4 and we'll just keep it as a
straight line so we'll do 1 2 3 4 comma
1 2 3 4 XY coordinates and this is X
and why if you want to call it that but
it's your first set of coordinates in
your second set for the Matt plot
library and will simply show this
PLT - oh and when we do shift enter or
hit the Run button typo there I forgot
to put in the pipe lot but since that's
what we're using Matt plot library type
lot is PLT and when I run that we're
doing a nice straight line so it's gonna
go ahead and do the figure size it does
a basic figure size 640 by 480 with one
axes and you can see it just plays it
right in line so we can do a lot of work
with this as far as any of your pot your
Matt plot library it's gonna come in in
line and you'll see a nice display here
again just a diagonal straight line
we're just playing and if I wanted to I
could do something let's do this and
just change this double-click on it to
edit it below is a graph and so we have
our title below is a graph of a diagonal
line and then we have our nice plot of a
diagonal line and I can even break this
up and let's do this insert cell below
so now I've added a cell below this one
I'm gonna put this to take our plot show
and I'm gonna put it down to cells I'm
gonna do this one as a mark up and we'll
do cell type or mark down I call the
mark up and we'll say welcome to my
simple graph and so when I run this it
makes a nice mark up and then I run this
cell and we get a nice plot show so we
have a plot plot and I run it and you
can see welcome to my simple graph so
everything's nice and orderly this is
kind of nice because once you set this
up you can see how you can create a nice
presentation while working on your
project you don't have to even get out
of your project to generate the
information you want to show to the
shareholders and if it takes too long
let's say we're running this script you
know what that's just kind of overloaded
here do a lot of plotting I'm gonna run
it and it happened too fast if your
kernel gets stuck you can always
interrupt the kernel you can restart it
or interrupt it usually you restarted
because it's loaded data in there and
you want to reload the data but if I
restarted here remember we did that
before whatever I had that ran up here
where I said hello
- hello simply learned that's gone I
have to rerun this cell to reload that
data into the variable hello and of
course I can do run cells and selected
below or run cells and just run off I
can run it on it goes all the way to the
bottom so it's not a big deal if you
forget but you can easily run all the
cells do you want to point out one thing
since we did a run all we're still doing
some plotting in here and coming down
for whatever reason if you go to the top
you'll see up here in the tab there's an
hourglass
that means this kernel is running we'll
go ahead and interrupt this kernel you
know taking a moment to interrupt the
kernel and stop it you'll see that shut
down in just a minute
another there's so many cool things you
can do with Jupiter I get so excited
it's so simple there's not like a huge
number of hidden commands on the page
although it certainly you can there's
all kinds of back-end stuff you can do
one of the things you can do in here is
I go up to file and if you go under file
you'll see down here download as and I
can download it as a notebook which it
automatically saves as I can download it
as a Python dot PI file so it would
remove the non Python stuff in there and
you just have your regular Python file
and I can also download it as an HTML
there's also the Ju ice rest markdown
but I love the HTML my goodness I click
on here in the machine but I'm gonna go
ahead and open it there it opens up in
my browser and I can actually take this
code and just put it onto a web page so
now I have my HTML code of what I just
did you know that's a lot of that's
pretty cool
you can flip that over so quick and easy
so we've covered a lot of stuff we've
covered that it runs in a single cell
we've covered going through the kernel
interrupts restart restart clear output
restart run all we've discussed cells
where you can run the cells below run
the cells above run all almost common we
covered cell type we've gone under file
and we've seen where you can go ahead
and download as a different version
there's a lot of other things in here
but those are the main ones you can save
and create a checkpoint you can rename
it we clicked up here to rename but if
you're under view let's say I don't want
the header on I can still just go under
file and rename so if I don't want to
see the header name with that extra
screen space which I like I can toggle
that on and off I can toggle the toolbar
off put that back on with all the
shortcuts and to wrap it up one more
reference
let me just close these out if you do
jupiter notebook repositories on git and
i just go to training notebook
repositories on the github you'll see
all kinds of stuff on here that you can
go practice with you can pull what
somebody else is working on the uh
practical AI deep learning - you have
two cores tensorflow examples that's the
google tensorflow i mentioned earlier
which is a neural network hanson machine
learning i don't know what any of these
actually are other than by the name but
you can see they have a lot of stuff
that's published on github which helps
you get started you find something
you're interested in you do a search on
github and you'll find that you put a
notebook on there gets you some hands-on
and then just regular coding how do you
become a good Python programmer you
write Python code that's the basics so
thank you for joining us today we
covered anaconda and Jupiter notebooks
for more information come visit us at
www.fortuigence.com Lord up and get
certified click here